at least once a year I like to bring in
some of my Kevin's famous chili the
trick is to undercook the onions
everybody is going to get to know each
other in the pot I'm serious about this
stuff I'm up the night before pressing
garlic and dicing whole Tomatoes I toast
my own ancho chiles it's a recipe passed
down from Malone's for generations it's
probably the thing I do best all right
sorry sir sorry I just had to grab my
wah
[Music]
fine I was trying something and it
didn't work hey bro listen I was trying
to buy this handcrafted mahogany wood
model of b-25 mitchell Panchito aircraft
for me don't sass me and I went to this
website and this ad popped up that said
hey Ron Swanson check out this great
offer what's your question my question
is what the hell like how do they know
who you are yeah okay um there are these
things called cookies where like if you
go to a site and buy something it'll
remember you and then create ads for
other stuff you might want to buy so it
learns information about me
seems like an invasion of privacy dude
if you think that's bad go to Google
Earth and type in your address hey there
Boyle how was your weekend
well actually I got a little sick oh
really I'm sorry to hear that man yeah
bullets over Broadway was on TV I came
down with a big old Dianne Wiest
infection
like ooh brownies I'm taking two so I
can parcel them up and eat them at my
leisure later on much healthier you're
taking two yeah um but one of them is
for Toby yeah why don't you send that to
him in Costa Rica I'm just gonna hand it
to him right now
okay weirdo why is that why is that
weird she said she was gonna give it to
him right now
she's probably going to you because they
said thanks to each other yeah they used
to Toby works here again oh can you
imagine oh no I don't know I don't know
what you should probably just meander
back there take a look see he's sick
he's back dare I you know what I'm going
to for old times sake
great practical joke Jim got me go to
the annex no God no God please no no no
no 901 Amy Santiago is officially late
for the first time ever all right let's
do this who's got theories alarm didn't
go up all three alarms all with battery
backup come on who wants to take this
seriously
oh she was taken in her sleep that's
what I'm talking about super dark Boyle
the way more plausible than the Sarge's
idiotic alarm clock theory I bet she
tucked herself into bed too tight and
got stuck maybe she fell into another
dimension where she's interesting it's
9:00 a.m. why is no one working Amy
Santiago is a few minutes late and we're
all trying to guess why I like to play
I'd say she's in line at the bank this
is fun it is fun but you're all wrong
she clearly slipped through a subway
grate and is having terrible sex with a
mole man there she is
Amy where have you been we've been
worried sick do you care to explain
yourself I'm just 70 seconds late it's
not a big deal don't worry about it
Santiago you will tell us and you will
tell us now there's a problem at the
bank hot day while they repaint the
lines in the parking lot we're asking
everyone to do street parking
I'm not street parking my Mercedes well
everyone is I'm doing it because nobody
wants to steal a Saturn all right moving
on to recycling
you okay run just a little tooth pain
I'm fine
continue okay each department will be
getting blue bins do you need to go to
the dentist
run I don't like dentists just a second
[Applause]
Oh God I'm sorry everybody what were we
talking about recycling dentist pulled
the tooth out yesterday but it's always
a good idea to demonstrate to your
co-workers that you are capable of
withstanding a tremendous amount of pain
plus it's always fun to see Tom faint
[Laughter]
it's kind of blurry it's better question
what kind of bear is best that's a
ridiculous question
false black bear well that's debatable
there are basically two schools of
thought fact bears eat beets so bears
beets battlestar galactica bears do not
what is going on what are you doing last
week I was in a drugstore and I saw
these glasses $4 and it only cost me $7
to recreate the rest of the ensemble and
that's a grand total of lemon dollar you
know what imitation is the most sincere
form of flattery so I thank you energy
theft is not a joke Jim millions of
families suffer every year Michael oh
that's funny
Michael exit people give me hope pull me
up you're too heavy I don't weigh 82
pounds
[Music]
[Music]
use the surge of fear and adrenaline to
sharpen your decision-making okay I am
[Music]
a denture
employees of Dunder Mifflin this has
been a test of our emergency
preparedness there is no fire it was
only a simulation what fire not real
this was merely a training exercise so
what have we learned
oh come on it's not real
daily Stanley you will not die Stanley
Stanley baracus Brendan you are black
satellite I want to give him
mouth-to-mouth
don't give him out the mouth for this do
you recognize any of these men I was
hiding in the vacuum stall so I didn't
see his face but I heard him he was
singing along to the music at the bar do
you remember what he was singing I think
he was that song I want it that way
Backstreet Boys I'm familiar okay number
one could you please sing the opening
two I want it that way
really okay you are my fire number two
keep it going the one desire number
three believe when I say number four I
want it that way tell me why ain't
nothin
me why ain't nothin but a mistake now
number five I never wanna he say chills
literal chills it was number five number
five killed my brother oh my god I
forgot about that part
you